welcome to just the facts with me Jay
jonah Jameson friends I know what you're
thinking with Wilson Fisk removed from
action the city is safe well not quite
because as we all know nature abhors a
vacuum
and right now Nature has taken the form
of hammerhead the nefarious mafia done
with a cranium only a mother could love
trust me when I say that this guy is no
ordinary mafioso
he's absolutely ruthless rumor has it
he's been on a mission to personally
replace the other Mafia dons and if he
has to take out half the police force to
do it well that's what he considers a
good day I know you're probably
wondering how is all this possible well
let's just say some high-tech Sable
international weaponry may have fallen
off the back of a truck if you catch my
drift
[Music]
and where might you be asking is
spider-man in all this well it seems
he's eavesdropping on local citizens and
dingy no-name bars chasing cars like a
stray dog playing around with that screw
go loser and of course spending all his
free time making fancy new suits instead
of stopping the mozzie a turf war he
helped start in the first place there
normally I'd suggest letting the police
but my sources say the pressure has
gotten to captain Yuri Watanabe so when
this city can't count in its police who
does it turn to the government the
military no of course not we just hand
the keys over to that masked Menace
spider-man JA I'm gonna need more coffee
to get through this one hey what does it
take to get a tenth of a coffee around
here girl until next time has the final
word with me J jonah Jameson
[Music]
today's